um it's my first time in a confessional  but um well so far I really enjoyed the  opening and I also really I don't know  why but I really like my position I mean  I like that I I haven't played in so  long so I'm just trying to play  interesting just and I just every move  that I make I try to think about the  months that I didn't get to play just  because I'm a student so I'm a little  worried because the first I mean the  opening that I played wasn't something  that I usually play and I didn't expect  there to be a first- trip expected to  play either c4 or d4 but she went with  my earth tree and I'm I chose this  opening because I thought that the pawn  structure is well I liked it was  comfortable and I like the 94 idea and I  honestly don't know I I don't know how  I'm gonna feel after the game but I'm  happy about my decisions so 400 get  picks the game